obsolete iya was your first feature film
let's talk about Sundance a blind
submission did you know anyone there
what happened Sundance was a submission
on the last day of submissions and it
was walked in not posted or fedexed I
walked it in by myself I didn't trust
anybody else to do it that day Diane and
I had been given two tickets to go and
see the dalai lama talk and it was the
last day and of submissions and I said
to Dan you go and see the dalai lama i'm
gonna go and deliver the film over to
sundance damn went and saw the dalai
lama I went and delivered the film at
sundance and when I got there that the
performer is is that it's in a manila
envelope with a particular code number
written on top that you deliver to the
counter and then that person at the
counter of the office in Sundance's
office in Beverly Hills they take that
envelope and put it in the pile and I
watched where it went in the pile and I
looked at the pile and I was a gas at
the amount of envelopes that were
standing upright all the way down this
corridor and I thought to myself well
there goes nothing because there were so
many envelopes I just didn't think we
had a chance so yeah we did not know I
he we do nobody there we just gave in a
blind submission then when the
programmers got to it it was in a slush
pile and the guy had watched for movies
previously and this was his fifth movie
to watch and that was exactly how it was
selected for competition at Sundance he
watched for movies and then he got two
hours which you've seen our movie it's
pretty slow I mean there's less cuts in
our movie than there is in a 60 second
car commercial you know so he watched
our movie after watching for of the
movies and then he
decided that it was going to go into
another pile which was further up the
food chain and that was how we got into
competition at Sundance and we so we'd
knew absolutely nobody and we really I
mean we didn't have high expectations we
just felt like it was worth submitting
you know as you do and it was the first
thing we've submitted it to the film was
not finished we had done we had not
completed sounder at that point it was
not color corrected and so we said those
things to do and then I was out in
Wyoming and you know this is like a
couple months later and I was working
with a director on a script there and I
was it was funny it's just that funny
thing with timing like I had just had
this one night where I really like for
the first time I actually really doubted
how we had made the film and what the
film was and the whole time making it
and you know in post everything I just I
just I loved it and I love the process
and I was just like this is it this is
great and whatever happens it doesn't
matter this has been amazing and I've
learned so much and I've grown so much
and what happens beyond this is it's all
fine and this one particular night you
know I just had this night where I was
like I'm out Wyoming I'm in the middle
of nowhere and haven't seen anyone and
I'm sure that fed into it where I was
just like Diane you've screwed up you
know like you know like the movie you
should have thought you should have been
more clever you know you should have got
the name cast and you should have done
this and you should have done it you'll
never get to do it again you'll never
make another movie and the very next day
I got up and there's an email from
Sundance saying you know it's just the
number that we can contact you at and I
remember I called you and then I called
Matt and I was like they're probably
just calling they probably just want to
call to say like you know thanks well
done try again next time do you know
like I really was like you know it can't
it can't be actually you know and then I
got that call and it was I scribed it
recently my blog I mean I literally when
it was sherry free low who called me one
of the programmers and I mean when she
said you know your film has been
selected i was literally sort of on the
floor crying i think because i just had
this really dark night you know this you
know i think i just been in that moment
of going you know you did screw it up
right and it's it's it's never going to
be seen anywhere and
and then and then that call came so with
rebel heart films and your your classes
that you're teaching that you're going
on the road I think you're going to
Seattle first to settle first what do
you plan to tell other filmmakers about
that same type of moment where hey it's
the last day and I've got tickets to go
see the dalai lama do i do i take the
chance and submit and how do my how do I
know my film is actually ready you know
no I mean you said it wasn't color
corrected and the sound wasn't yeah okay
the sound was and I think like to be
honest vessels like sometimes I think
they're really used to seeing films in
that sort of condition you know so I
think like if it's you know if the cut
is finished like you've edit you know
you've edited you've lot of picture and
you've just got like some things like
some technical sound color to do like I
think they'll be able to tell from that
if it's a film that's for them that year
you know I also believe in another angle
of this question the bigger the festival
I believe the more seasoned and informed
the programmers and I think they're able
to discern between something that's
really truly unique and has a voice or a
quality that speaks and they can see
that in first viewing in something
that's not color corrected that's not
that sound properly done that doesn't
have music and all of the accoutrements
that go would have finished film I think
really high-end bigger festivals that's
not to disparage smaller festivals
because we've been to some great small
festivals around the world not just in
America but around the world the bigger
festivals have a more it seems like a
more seasoned more informed programmers
who do this for a living this is their
profession and as a profession they're
able to they're able to weed out you
know the good from the bad
it's also I think they're looking for
something like authentic something
that's unique something that's true and
something that certainly the programs at
Sundance said to me you know they said
like when we watched obsolete iya I said
you just see is pure love you know and
you know I was so moved when one of them
said that to me except though that is
how we made the film right it was there
was never a cynical decision like it was
always that thing what sort of like
here's the smart thing to do right
here's what conventional wisdom would
have you do and we always went but it's
not right for us so we're gonna do it
like this you know so we're gonna cast
their best friend in the lead role we're
not going to you know go with the more
named actress we know we're just it and
we just did everything in that sort of
way and I think that that is ultimately
what gave it the chance to stand out you
know I think those programmers see
thousands of movies and they see
thousands of movies that are trying to
get into Sundance you know and i think
our film wasn't trying to get in sunday
our film was just trying to be its own
weird unique thing right which some
people are gonna love and some people
gonna hate you know because it's just
what it is but it's certainly none of
the decisions we made in that movie
we're sort of geared towards how do we
impress the programmers at Sundance or
how do we get a movie into there and I
think one of the problems for a lot of
films and something you know to me that
really is a message that we want to
impart people through rebel heart is
just that thing about be true to
yourself like make the film that you
will love you know and trust in that
don't try and second-guess what you
think the program is at Sundance are
like you're gonna like don't in there
for go oh well we'll get this person
because she was in another movie at
Sundance two years ago and oh we'll get
this music because you know they're
really popular and people will think
that you don't do any of that like
really just you know it's like it's like
filtering out the noise in yourself to
just find your own heart and your own
true story and I really feel like when
you do that and if you do that with an
authentic intent that is how you're
gonna make a film that's going to stand
out and that's how you're going to make
a film that will get into Sundance for
instance you know but the more that
you're thinking in a cynical way or you
know sort of a manipulative way I just
think that's a they see a thousand you
know five thousand movies and most of
them are doing
when I was making the film i just wanted
to I mean I knew it was gonna this is my
first film I was gonna it was either
going to be is going to make or break me
that first movie and I just did my best
as as cliche as it sounds I gave it
everything I had I mean I used to lay in
bed at night and and whatever your
higher power God is I used to I used to
pray to god I'd be I would say if if I
can't do anything else in my life just
let this happen let's Steel City happen
I won't just let this happen let me give
me just give me an opportunity because I
was you know working on the script and I
had John Hurt involved and you know I
was relying on the community of Alton I
had investors at alton and then i teamed
up with a production company in LA it
all came together in this very strange
way that I've never had an experience
like that sense and that was back when
you know so it all came together we
shoot this movie I get a great cast I'm
in the middle of editing the film and my
appendix almost burst and I'm editing
and I'm so into the I'm so into editing
this movie and I don't go to the
hospital and I wait and then I get
violently ill so I go to the hospital
and I have to have my appendix to have
an appendectomy and I'm like oh man and
so then that happens in the middle of
editing and then finished editing the
movie and I'm broke I have no money so I
start working in a warehouse and as a
warehouse manager and then that whole I
never really thought about Sundance that
much because we submitted to Toronto a
rough cut and we didn't get in and you
know the thing in the voice in the back
here mind says well if Toronto didn't
accept you then Sundance may not accept
you but they were repping another movie
we had not them we were working with a
company called traction media who was it
was a producer's rep and they had a
movie called Half Nelson that they that
was told they were in the very
that half nelson was in and they was
repping they were repping steel city as
well and it worked out they I got a call
that we were in so you're you're working
in this warehouse you've already you
edited the entire film movies done at
this but movies dunno yeah and um and
you were gonna pass on Sunday and she
thought well if we don't get into I mean
I mean I knew I mean I'm not bad i mean
obviously we will I was enthusiastic
about going but I you know I'm working a
nine-to-five job to pay my bills I'm not
gonna I was proud of the movie and and I
didn't my production company submitted
the film so I didn't do any of the
paperwork and I don't know where were
you in your life when you heard did you
get a phone call you I've got a phone
call in the in the warehouse i was
working in really yeah saying are you
gonna be around later a nice i get off
work at five it takes me an hour to
drive back home and my producer said
well they're gonna call you when is a
good time to call you i said well i
didn't want him call me at work so i
said after 6 i'll be home so i get home
and it's the day before it's like two
days before thanksgiving or maybe the
day before i got a call from carolina
bresco and she said would you would you
like to go to Sundance and I said to ski
or for the film festival when she see us
know your and we want to include your
movie and it was great so then we went
and and celebrated so the job gives you
time off no I had the job let me go
because I told him I need to all this
time off to go to Sundance and my boss
said what do you what Sundance I said
it's kind of a thing for filmmakers and
he goes okay I mean and that was it so
you had to quit you had to give him yeah
I mean there was there was like it was
like a mutual departure right wow so you
go you come back then what is you you
come back to Alton after i was living in
la at the time so I go back to Los
Angeles and okay taking these meetings
and reading scripts and play in the play
in the game
um I guess what everyone does after they
go through an experience like that and
looking for my next project and then one
of your actors is given a nomination for
what it's at Best Supporting aurait
Barry got an independent spirit award
for best supporting actor which was
fantastic because he's so great in the
movie and you know when you make a
low-budget movie and you ask these
actors who have been working since
before you were born who have been done
all this work you're so privileged for
them to come do your little movie for no
money I mean seriously it's a big deal
when you have people that believe in you
and they come they leave their home they
leave their family they go to a location
and they do your movie and when they get
recognized for that on a big scale it's
it makes it all worth it and they
realize that and they see that because
so many independent films that get made
that don't get recognized they're due
recognition or they're bad one or the
other but I was fortunate that I got
recognized and was able to open that
door that yes I can work with these
people again they trust me so going back
to that those nights you know praying to
God whatever did you expect that all
this was going to happen I mean this is
this is pretty amazing for socially a
first-time feature film maker I know you
had the experience with the script lab
or the contest but I mean was that the
intention or you just really needed to
get the story out there was that Worf I
just needed some money to make my film I
was figuring out a way of who would give
me an opportunity first-time director I
mean I was young and I was figuring out
how can I start my career how can i what
what's it going to take for me to get
the yacht this opportunity what am I
going to have to do and I just wouldn't
give up I mean I was just I was when I
was writing still city I was working the
graveyard shift in a hotel in Century
City and I was writing the script
longhand on hotel stationary I'm
seriously I was writing all these
dialogue scene because i had to all this
time to kill I wasn't allowed to have a
computer I couldn't write the script on
the hotel
interface obviously so I wrote the whole
first draft on hotel stationary I mean I
had like 85 hotel stationery sheets of
just scenes and dialogue I'll never
forget that staying up like in this my
hotel outfit writing Steel City it's
kind of wild to think about we really
wanted to actually keep it out of the
news until we premiered at sundance we
didn't want people going into Sundance
thinking I'm going to go see this iphone
movie with weed nobody knew actually
until the very end of the film when the
final credits it says shot me iphone 5s
and that was the first time anybody
outside our small circle knew that this
film was shot on that so then when you
do the QA yeah afterward right we're
most of the questions directed toward no
5050 yeah right now what seems to happen
in these q and A's is that fifty percent
of it is about the tech and then fifty
percent of a of it is about the trans
movement and how we approached that
sensitive subject matter and being from
outside that world how we decided to to
actually form a story work with our with
our actors and and and make this film
that was our first film and we took it
to we got accepted to Sundance in 2006
took it to the festival and there was a
very intense bidding war for that film
we ended up with 77 offers on the table
from you know all the big distributors
and we sold it for a million dollars we
only we had only spent a little over a
hundred thousand dollars to get the
movie to Sundance okay so we spent a
year making it we spent about a hundred
thousand dollars and change to make that
cut of the film
and we sold it for a million bucks and I
remember telling our agent at Sundance
our agent is John Schloss from cinetic
media I said I'm really worried about
selling our film for a million dollars
I'm afraid that I'm afraid that you know
we're gonna be one of those infamous
films that come out of sundance like oh
they pay too much and that movie
underperformed and like I didn't want to
I didn't want to have all that I was
like we should sell it for less he's
like no he's like first of all a million
dollars is not that much money for a
movie he's like you've made a really
good film that a lot of people want to
see so that's that's the right price and
and you know and you have it it's it's
we already have a deal we already shook
hands on this deal what I didn't know
was that when after sundance you know
some dances in january and we were in
theaters we were in about five hundred
theaters at summer in June we came out
in June later on that year we had a lot
of work to do on the film between
selling it and releasing it we had to
film out we had to pay for that was a
hundred thousand dollars and over
100,000 hours to film out we had to
license all the music we did a lot more
graphics we did a lot more editing I
mean it really started to add up and by
the time we were sitting in the theaters
on opening night at the ifc center in
new york city we had spent a total of
almost seven hundred thousand dollars so
do the math we walked away with three
hundred thousand dollars now that's
great I mean if I could do that if I can
do that every year I would do I would do
that every year unfortunately that's
that's that's not what normally happens
I think on a lot of these films I mean I
hate to say it because it sounds really
discouraging but I think on a lot of
these documentaries you're lucky even to
break even and what we're finding
nowadays is that if you don't have
if you don't have good partners when you
go out to make these films you're really
going to be in trouble on this film we
had an if you build it we had great
partners the Sundance was a big partner
the John D and Catherine T MacArthur
Foundation film independent the candida
foundation which is out of the East
Coast the wind coat foundation we did a
Kickstarter campaign we want an
independent spirit award we won the
bright future award presented by
Unilever project sunlight that was a
twenty-five-thousand-dollar award that
we won I mean we had an army behind us
really to make this film if we didn't
have that we probably wouldn't be
sitting here in my house because we
probably would have lost our house we
probably had to sell our house I mean it
was so financially challenging for us to
make this film Christine and I and our
partner Neal Baer you know we we've been
at this a long time we've been making
movies and Neal's a tremendously
successful television writer and
showrunner and we thought we had it all
figured out and then we made this movie
about a small town in North Carolina
that took three years to make and it was
hard to raise money I was challenging so
you know word play was great and we made
money on that film and we also sort of
launched our film careers at the same
time but I think more often than not
these movies you do them for other than
financial reasons and if you are lucky
enough to make money on a film more
often than not you fold that into your
next project and it's tied up in the
next one so yeah it's it's great if
anyone is thinking about like becoming a
millionaire I wouldn't recommend making
documentary films because it's very
unusual that that would
case it could happen but more often than
not it won't well just to talk about why
we started slamming it's a little bit is
in 90 you know 95 was in eighteen
nineteen ninety-five feels like it you
notify it was an interesting time in
independent film you know there had been
this great crop of filmmakers you know
sundance film makers in the early 90s
and then by 95 that a lot of the
institutions of independent film were
sort of going Hollywood so that was he
or Merrimack's became part of disney was
a year fine line became part of Warner
Brothers was a year fox launched fox
searchlight it was kind of the studio
ization of independent film and Sundance
was kind of part of you know that whole
change that whole you know shift and as
a result they were programming much more
second time directors directors with
working with bigger budgets and bigger
stars and that already had distribution
and it was kind of the Hollywood ization
of Sundance for one of a better term and
then we came along in 95 and we had just
finished Omaha the movie and you know we
actually premiered it at the what was
then called the I FFM or ifp market in
September and in previous year like the
previous year kevin smith had gotten
picked up there discovered by sundance
and became kevin smith you know and so
we all thought I well at least some of
us here we'll get we'll go to Sundance
and as it turned out that year out of
the 95 completed feature narrative
feature films at the ifp market not a
single one got picked up to go to Sunday
and so we're like oh man that's kind of
a drag but at the same time we had
distributors telling us good
distributors saying we love your film we
want to give you distribution if you get
into Sundance and they said it with no
shame it was just very matter-of-fact
like yeah we'll pick you up if you get
into Sundance because and in really
Sundance was kind of all or nothing you
know basically if you got in great but
if you didn't you wouldn't get
distribution you wouldn't get your next
film made you wouldn't get producers you
wouldn't get agents you wouldn't get
into other regional festivals you
wouldn't get onto into international
festivals because they all use the
Sundance guide is the kind of
handbook so we actually heard of a
couple filmmakers the prior year in 94
who had done renegade screenings in Park
City when they didn't get in Sundance's
so it was Trey Parker and Matt Stone had
their first film cannibal the musical
which was their film coming out of
university colorado this way before
South Park and then also a guy named
James merendino had a film called the
upstairs neighbor and separately they
done little screenings in hotel rooms
but had gotten a little bit of press for
it and we knew tre and Matt had the same
lawyer as us I think at the time so we'd
heard about these guys we thought okay
well that's an interesting idea and
especially and this is largely Dana
Altman's idea to kind of combine it with
the concept of getting filmmakers from
all over the country to kind of help
each other and combine resources and and
then we said all right well let's stick
a name on it called slam dance and you
know so we got ultimately a dozen
features and dozen shorts and we showed
up in Park City and did our thing you
know and and and people loved our spirit
and what we were doing and it was a lot
of fun and even while we were there the
first year we actually put a deposit
down Peter Baxter who's now running
slamming so he and I put a deposit down
on I think it was his money I made sure
it was his money yeah on the the yarrow
hotel which which ultimately was our
venue than for the next year and kind of
with the idea that okay there's this
niche of first-time directors working
with limited budgets who don't have
distribution that was being left behind
by Sundance and so it worked for us why
not help other filmmakers in subsequent
years and I said that's a crazy idea
it'll never fly we should just get out
while the goings good and he's like now
let's stick with it and and we have now
we're heading into our 20th year and
over the years we've shown you know it
has been beneficial to a lot of
filmmakers who you know I mean I'm sure
their careers would have been okay but
you know we are very proud to have shown
the first films by you know Christopher
Nolan greg mottola
marc forster he's got planet Z or World
War Z coming at Matt Ben Zeitlin we
showed her his for short Lena Dunham
hearse for short Lynn Shelton Drake
Doremus Oren Peli you know all kinds of
Lists kind of goes on and on and so it's
definitely it's it's shown that there's
a niche for Slamdance even though
literally by the second year I mean as
early as the second year after we
started Sundance had kind of responded
by creating different by expanding their
offerings and actually first it was
called the rectum necessary the spectrum
section and then now it's called next
but it's actually the same idea you know
they've added other sections so they do
show more films and they show more fun
by first-time directors and I so I think
we've kind of kept that pressure on them
to to stay more relevant but the reality
is they're still so many films and
there's still enough good ones that you
know there's enough for everyone so it's
not very it's not dissimilar also from
can haz Directors Fortnight which
started in nineteen 68 or 69 by a group
of disgruntled directors and it's still
going on you know 42 years later or
something so so you know it's it's a
yeah we didn't invent the wheel you know
it's a tradition in the film festival
world and it goes back to other art
institutions for hundreds of years back
two kinds of filmmakers submit their
films to Sundance every year and and
only a couple hundred or accepted so if
someone came to you and said I want to
get my phone
dance what would you tell them besides
you know great felt paperwork at the
hundred or check or whatever it is if
it's is it finished or they haven't made
it yet because I would have advised on
both sides okay I think it wasn't major
what I would say then is I feel like and
I'm guessing here but I do feel like
I've gotten to know the sunniest people
over the years and when I look at the
films I do feel like they're people
argued nepotism a lot you know they're
like oh it's movies within develop I've
never personally seen that you know I've
never seen someone get in just because
in fact I've seen people not get in that
you would think that they should because
of what net because of those nepotism
things I don't think that Trevor and
John run it that way at all i think they
truly program off their God and I mean
every film festivals of business so
there's always that side to it but you
know and that's why they have premier
sections and stuff like that but I think
when you look at the competition section
I think they just choose stuff that's
its bold I think they're looking for
something that's you know has some kind
of unique identity to it that's what I
would say to someone like make sure your
film has europe don't try to make a
movie that you think would fit the
Sundance mold do you know make a movie
that is just of your own and I think
next is really epitomized that and why I
forget some of the most important I mean
more the most exciting movies happening
there in the next category because
they're just they're usually really
really unique identities and I think
that mean I would say there's anyone
independent of sundance like just make
sure your movie reflects yourself you
know don't try to even even when comes
out some music either way it's gonna
look like don't don't try to make it
look that way because another movie did
it you know that's always my least
favorite question to answer someone will
be like what what other movie do you
think this movie will be like you know
before you make it and I'm like oh I'm
not I think it's gonna be the way I
think I'm gonna make it i'll have
illustrations to show that but I'm not
gonna compare it to and I think that's
the most important thing and I think
when it comes to submissions I think
you've got to formalize it you've got to
do this a formal submission process I
don't think it you know look are
thousands of films I don't think it
hurts not to pull strings but I don't
think if you have some kind of some way
just to make sure your to get your name
mentioned not to say that you should
show up I don't believe in you know that
kind of thing I don't think I need to
campaign for your film you know I think
the film will stand it's on on its own
and they do watch the movies and
everything like that but to inquire or
nudge or ask a friend to put in a good
word or whatever I do that all the time
for my friends with other film festivals
I don't think that necessarily
guarantees you or gets you in or
anything like that but it doesn't hurt
to just for someone to remember your
name and have it be set I mean that's
advice I would say a totally independent
of something it's just for anything in
life nevertheless you know to be bold
and be persistent you know those things
that exist but I think also the most
important thing I think to submit to
Sundance is to not expect to get in I
don't that's not like it sounds negative
i just think in a positive way I put too
much on myself my fur when my first film
didn't get in it was like rushing to me
and it shouldn't be it shouldn't be no
no festival should determine your worth
that much you know and I'm glad I had
that experience of not getting in you
know it didn't I I've learned to not let
any festival be the indicator of the
quality of your film you know only you
should be the indicator of that you know
and so that's I think what I would tell
people first and foremost but you know
too I always say don't expect it but
plan on it you know if you can shoot
your film a little sooner and have
enough time to edit it to get it in time
like try to do it try to try to do what
you can to have it there and it be
placed in a position where it could be
accepted you know um also trust that
they are used to seeing rough cuts they
saw really rough cut of my film and I
was really uncomfortable about it but
they that's their job is to see to see
what the film is guns are going to
become you know festival programmers see
rough versions of films all the time and
my initial on my first film I was like
it needs to be totally finished and it
needs to be sound mix and everything you
need to know there needs to be no room
for what they think but I realized that
it's actually okay like they're they're
really tuned to that to the filmmaker
and process in the post-production
process and make sure you're submitting
something you can stand behind you know
that to me feels like like if you never
get a chance to people play their films
at festival sometimes I mean like well
it's still a work in progress and I was
like no way I need to like brenton of
course you always want to make changes
to your film but I played it played my
film at the cut at Sundance which it
very little time to finish I played that
there with the assumption I'll never get
to touch again and financially i
probably won't but you know i had to be
okay with that what other people i know
that well i'm still thinking about doing
this and tweaking this and like you
probably shouldn't be charging people
naughty to see your film then that's
just that's just my opinion
everyone rounds a different way but in
terms of getting in that's what I think
it's a plan for it put your best foot
forward you know submit it formally try
to inquire if you can if you know
someone who knows a program or just you
know say hey put in a good word for me I
I would say just to do that just to
create awareness of the project but
having said that I night program for
festivals before not some dance but I
real i watch everything every festival
programme I know they do watch things
there's always this sort of angst about
well they will they really watch it or
not and they will because that I feel
like the true festival programmer you
know when you meet the people have been
doing it their whole lives what they
want they want like I said when I can
read script the first time I want to
like when they put in a movie I think
they always want to love it they want to
discover that movie that like someone
made in their backyard in Tennessee
that's like unheard of and unparalleled
and totally unique and creative like
that's what their desire is for and so I
think you want you want to keep that in
mind that they're they're not sitting
I've rarely seen a festival programmer
that's a cynic you know where usually
they have that optimism of wanting to
find something great in the middle of
thousands of thousands of movies and
most of those thousands of movies aren't
you know it's strange you think like God
who made twelve thousand movies think I
think a lot of times they're really Rock
you know sometimes the movies are really
rough and maybe don't aren't unique
enough but you know it's I do think
everything does get considered